so Brian I understand there was a
follow-up to Steel City in terms of a
big project that you were hoping to work
on
well after you know after going through
the the Steel City experience and being
at Sundance you know I had I was very
fortunate to go through that experience
with with my first film and I wanted to
keep on the trajectory of telling my own
unique stories and being you know
developing sense of an auteur and being
a bonafide writer director and after
Sundance I things were happening very
quickly and I was still relatively young
I was I think twenty six after that
happened and I was hired to to write the
Jeff Buckley biopic and and I spent a
good portion of time a little under a
year working on that story and the
living in New York for a small portion
of that and really got was really
inspired by his music and then when that
unfortunately came to a head and I had
to sort of exit the project
I wrote this other script called
mechanics of ordinary living and I just
come off a Midwest based movie called
stick you know Steel City and after
being in LA I wanted to tap into the
sort of the blue-collar working-class
community of Los Angeles and that's
where the mechanics of ordinary living
screenplay
came from and it takes the place where
it was plated to take um it takes place
in Tujunga California which is north of
Los Angeles I think it's maybe 12 or 15
miles north of LA something like that
and the story you know I'm so proud of
it and I am so very proud of it and I
and it was one of those things that the
story was about in an airplane mechanic
who worked at Burbank Airport and he was
kind of he had a wife and two children
and
his his teenage daughter goes missing I
mean not but but we know where she goes
and it's just about this family
this young airplane mechanic trying to
find his teenage daughter and he teams
up with her high school science teacher
and they go to Mexico to try and find
her and it's just a really good I was so
proud of it and the movie was a quad the
script was acquired by oxymoron
entertainment and we were slated to
shoot and you know budgets were being
made and offers were being made to
actors and you know since I gave up I
surrendered control I once they pulled
the plug and said you know we're not
going to move forward I couldn't my
hands were tied so I had to I'm in a
position where I have to reacquire the
property in order to move forward with
the movie and obviously I'm a filmmaker
so like you know after that experience I
just had to move on what time frame are
we talking about Steel City would have
been January about six I got hired to do
the Buckley biopic March or April of oh
six lived in New York get the summer of
Oh six and then the whole the mechanics
of ordinary living was like later oh six
in death 2007 was when that happened and
when did you know that it was probably
not going to happen at the end of oh
seven yeah mid oh seven when I was
meeting with with actors you know which
would have been great for my career
I just yeah I think they got cold feet
and the financier was coming off another
big movie that wasn't all that
financially successful and I think they
just got cold feet and you know wanted
to take a step back and then I was more
or less than I got offered a movie that
I was less enthusiastic about but I had
to find a reason something I could bring
to the table and that movie was the
cover-up which ended up going to
lifetime
so different than mechanics of ordinary
living and what I saw myself doing you
know this is based on a true story and I
was not allowed to interview the family
or even get close to their family
because they didn't approve of it so I
couldn't you know do what I needed to do
and it was just it was the whole thing
was in this bubble and because there was
other motives as to why the film was
getting made and I'm very proud of the
movement I think the movie is an
important film but at the end of the day
it was it was my follow up movie and it
it wasn't you know things could have
gone differently well going back to it
when when you felt some of the
excitement was going out on there and
what were you doing Liz I think that's
an interesting thing I mean did you kind
of have a a gut feeling that you know
what stuff's not happening which should
be on the other end and you started to
get nervous or the total surprised that
it didn't go through is it human in
regards to not being not being able to
have access to the family and all that
stuff
oh I'm sorry well I meant I'm I can I
can rephrase it the for the mechanics Oh
when when you felt that this project
that you were so excited about and that
really meant a lot to you was slipping
away on there and did you intuitively
know that or was this that were you
totally blindsided when you let you know
well I mean it was intuitive a little
bit because it was it's a bits of
progression of events emails aren't
return phone calls aren't returned
you know when offers to actors don't go
through like they should but it was all
real to me because you know the property
was acquired I would you know I was paid
I was meeting with actors on my in
through my setting up through my manager
at the time and the response to the
script was phenomenal I mean still is a
great script and you know one day you
know the movies you know someone owns
this you know and it it can still has it
it can still have a life and it was a
gradual thing and
the company that acquired the material
you know didn't didn't come didn't
originate in the film business or they
came from a different area of business
and kind of was able to through wealth
and connections you know like a lot of
people buy their way in and that's
that's fine but then guys like me who
like have to go out and work and develop
these scripts and bust our ass to get
films made you know a lot of times we're
like left left out left out in the rain
and but then again I'm fortunate that
they were interested in like anything
else
you